I would decriminalize marijuana or I
would have a federal tax on it though
apply that tax to building
rehabilitation centers politicians love
to promise cannabis decriminalization if
it includes a federal tax here's why
that's a terrible idea high taxes hinder
legal sales and perpetuate an illicit
Market in California state and local
taxes total as much as fourteen hundred
dollars per pound as a result an
estimated two-thirds of the state sales
are to the illicit Market a study of
Washington cannabis consumers cited
legal price as their number one reason
to buy from an illegal Source finally
cannabis is a multi-billion dollar
industry many companies use their
profits to voluntarily give back whether
that's the environment addiction
recovery or helping undo harm caused by
the drug war cannabis doesn't need
another tax the free market gives back
exponentially more than government ever
will so to all the politicians calling
for legalization if there's a tax on it
put that idea in your pipe and smoke it